six days to finish week 12 steelers
ravens on a wednesday afternoon that
extended into a wednesday evening
steelers emerge victorious 19 to 14.
we're going to break that all down and
commence the process of getting you
ready for
week 13 no game tonight because ravens
cowboys was moved
to tuesday as part of the extensive
reshuffling but the show is pft live we
have not been moved
yet still 7 a.m eastern here on peacock
series xm211 rear 9am eastern on nbcsn
hello to our friends in the uk and
ireland who get to see the program in
prime time on sky sports nfl and our
podcast audience everywhere good morning
christopher
friday for you oh yeah for the rest of
us
that's right eat it the rest of us some
it's my friday it's your
third day that's all right
they get me back on sunday so that's
where my kids and my family are always
like oh you're so lucky it's your friday
night you know and then
saturday night they're you know i'm like
well it's my sunday night now and
they're having a good time so
it all evens out oh you work on sundays
too
yeah oh boy i'm not complaining i'm not
complaining i'm just saying it's good
all right let's talk about it wanna talk
about football well we're good yeah
let's talk about football there was a
game yesterday and
i uh this is why
i would never ever ever
ever yesterday chris and i both picked
the steelers to win
he picked the ravens to cover what had
become a 10-point spread
i picked the steelers to cover the 10
and it looked like that was gonna happen
and my wife and i were eating dinner and
i was watching the game on my phone
uh discreetly well she knew she knew you
know this is the best thing about having
this for a job you get to watch football
and say i have to
you have to i have to i have to
but i i'd like walk away to get a little
more pasta and i come back in 19 to
seven as all of a sudden 19 to
hollywood yeah i swore yeah i swore
she's like what's wrong with you i think
well how much time do you have to get
into it but that that's kind of what
happens when
you're trying to wish away the final few
minutes of a game
a 70-yard touchdown can happen like that
and there goes your there goes your day
um
look the steelers i think fully expected
to destroy the ravens and they did then
have to sweat it out i mean
james washington makes a hell of a catch
to
keep the drive alive and kill the game
and it's like he did what kind of a
thing like this is you know and it
shouldn't have come down
and i think chris that's one of the
reasons why we heard
some disbelief and some saltiness from
oh my god like tomlin i love it ben
roethlisberger
juju smith schuster and tomlin's
four-minute press conference we have a
link to it at the story on pft
it's scary it's awesome he's mad yeah
the coach of an 11-0 team
acting like he's owen 11. how about
listening to some of what mike tomlin
had to say
when he sounded off here it is
we couldn't run the ball effectively
when we needed to we dropped too many
significant passes very
catchable makeable passes we didn't make
significant plays in the special teams
game
our kickoff coverage unit wasn't good
enough we turned the damn ball over
um we gave up big plays and critical
moments on defense can't have it
they converted a a long run on a
possession down
before the half unacceptable they had a
70 yard touchdown late in the game
unacceptable and so um we're fortunate
tonight
um it's good to to proceed um with the
victory i acknowledge that
but not a lot happen tonight to be proud
of or to be excited about
other than that you had uh uh some
red zone failures and a number of drop
passes
uh dude would you attribute that to
anything in particular
uh sucking uh-huh
yeah that's right it's simple and and
the full
four minutes went on just like that the
can't have it reminded me of the mike
singletary epic press conference from
all those years ago
uh but but look this is why tomlin is
one of the best coaches he's he's gonna
find nothing positive in what happened
last night because they should have won
that game
easily and there were so many
opportunities in the first half to blow
it open
and guys we're just dropping passes it's
like what's wrong with you guys
catch the football score the touchdown
let's go let's let's deliver the
knockout blow
so we can maybe pull some of these guys
off the field
because we got to play on monday night
against washington
the steelers have one fewer day than the
ravens to get ready for the next game
let's save some of these guys and start
refocusing on the next contest to try to
get to 12-0 it should have been that
kind of a night
not a five-point victory chris well no
no but this is like we've seen this part
of the pittsburgh steelers you know it's
been a few weeks
right but we saw this type of
performance against the dallas cowboys
with like
garrett gilbert at quarterback and you
just go what
there's no way they'll steamroll them
but they were kind of asleep at the
wheel that day too
obviously they thought they were going
to go in there and kind of just take
care of business blah blah blah i mean
the drop passes you know the third and
13
run up the middle everything like that
yeah it was
it was um not their best game and the
ravens came of course as we know
desperate you could tell the way their
dbs were playing and
tackling people and just their defense
in general
that there was definitely more of an
urgency on their side of the ball where
pittsburgh i think just kept going
we'll wear them down it'll happen
eventually
oh wait oh oh we're still in a game here
and i mean
you know in a game is an understatement
you know
like you said there was moments where
yeah you can go they could have
controlled the football game
and then they were this this damn close
to going whoa
you're gonna be down what 1412 at
halftime
i mean if the ravens don't kind of mess
up the end of the first half clock
management and that whole debacle there
too
so um it was a underwhelming performance
and it's a great teaching moment for
mike tomlin i mean that's where it's
going to be awesome
because they won and they kind of played
like crap
and he knows that and he can really lay
on him here the next few days a little
bit
and kind of like wake up the
organization again and get on
everybody's butt once again to go like
let's go we get we're a super bowl team
we're not we're not like oh we're just
gonna squeak by the jv
team and that's the lesson they're gonna
probably hear a lot this week
that really was a strange sequence that
could have put the ravens up at the end
of the half
second and goal from the one they run
the ball up the middle with gus
edwards who had nine carries for 10
yards on the night that is not a good
average he did score a touchdown but not
on that play he was stopped
and then it was tick tick tick all the
way down to three seconds left they
snapped the ball
luke wilson had the ball i mean it
should have been 14
12 at the half but they should have had
another crack at it at a minimum
they should have had a fourth down
opportunity to kick a field goal and
make it 12-10 or go for it again there
should have been
at least one more snap there and that's
just
that's the product of your backup
quarterback playing sure i think your
starter has the presence of mind to make
a better decision there
and and and spike the ball or
you just have to move faster there was
enough time to line up and get the ball
snapped when you snap one play at 26
and the next play at three there's time
in between there to get another play off
and then still have time left on the
clock if you move quickly enough yeah
i mean there's a lot of different ways
they could have attacked that you know
right i mean
first off the line let's just hit this
just before we break down the timeout
how about the laying on the pile
part of that you know little sequence
there by the pittsburgh steelers did you
find that egregious did you think that
ref should have stopped the clock there
to at least like
let the pile clear i thought so just a
little bit that would have saved them a
few seconds i thought that
the ravens kind of got screwed there
just what was your thought there
well i was on the air at the time oh
okay specifically
okay fine sorry sorry wait a minute real
that's why i love you
yeah that's the truth we were on the air
and i was
you told me not to watch the game while
i was on the air so i was trying my damn
just not to watch the game
i saw the luke wilson play right but uh
because shireen was talking at that time
but i didn't see the players laying on
but yeah well yeah you're not gonna
officially
you know you can you can you can uh
throw a delay a game
penalty in that situation it's easy to
do it's not just a matter of saying
we're going to stop the clock
you get and not that not that the
yardage would have made a difference but
it does stop the clock
and give the ravens an opportunity yeah
i mean what even like how terry mcauley
brought it up he by the letter of the
law i think he thought it should have
been a delay of the game they could have
certainly called it that way
either way to your point in what you
just said there
yeah i think at the very least it should
have been hey we're going to stop the
clock for a second
let the mosh pit clear out here spot the
ball start it up again
and then maybe the ravens aren't so
hectic in what to do
what not to do but either way they went
into this situation obviously
not with the the right game plan or the
approach you know
to me where it was messed up they had a
third and nine all right mike
and uh hill runs around the right tackle
for 19 yards to get the first down
okay so now there's plenty of time left
they're taking their time
before they have their first and goal
run from the four yard line
that to me is where you take your time
and you say
hey rg3 take your time here we're gonna
call
run play but if we don't get in i want
you to get right to this pass play right
here
blah blah blah blah blah right or
uh or you say i want to run a quick run
play and then you just
you formulate a game plan in that moment
is what i'm saying
and that's where i believe they messed
up they ran a run play
got down to the one yard line right and
now it's oh wait what are we gonna do
here what how do we want to approach
this
there seem to be miscommunication and
not knowing what they want to do
and they just call the timeout with 26
seconds left and
yeah that put them in a tough spot
especially when you're gonna run the
ball to play
after that and now whoa
it's a mosh pit of people and 26 seconds
is just not that much time
and that kind of scenario there and it
took a while and obviously that was a
debacle and they
lost an opportunity and and when you
have a team like that that that has an
offense it just feels like it was
slapped together on the fly you can't
afford to squander those opportunities i
think it's one of the reasons why the
defense was playing so well
yeah my guess is john harbaugh grabbed
each of those guys before the game and
said if we have any chance of winning
this game
right we need you to step up and give us
the best effort that you've ever given
us in your entire career
and and uh you know it helped i don't
know whether it was guys
trying to bracing for for impact or
trying to run the ball before they had
in their hands but
the drops were unacceptable and i can
understand why mike tomlin
was as upset as he was ben rothersberger
had a season-high
51 passes but they they can't get the
running game going benny snell did have
60 yards which uh
uh you know probably better than what
you would have thought given the extent
to which they threw the ball
but but this win ugly they got they got
five left now and they've got the bills
they've got the colts they have the
browns again
if they're 15-0 going into that browns
game they're going to see the absolute
best effort
that they've ever seen from the
cleveland browns it's going to be a lot
like the
the patriots giants game from week 17 of
2007 where you want to do everything you
can to be the team that keeps
someone from going up undefeated and
especially if it's someone from your own
division so they're going to have some
ti
washington's not going to be easy
washington will not in division
contention the only
easy one on there is at bengals so uh
but but it's i i think that i think
every game is going to be close
it's not going to matter and you know
the steelers keep trying to
to pull a rabbit out of their hat week
in and week out for most of these games
the only team they have blown out
convincingly with the browns and the
bengals the rest of the games could have
gone either way
yeah well that's right i mean last night
first off the ravens match up really
well with the pittsburgh steelers
you know the way they run the ball
pittsburgh likes to create all this
chaos with their front seven
so baltimore with the pulling guards
like chris collinsworth pointed out and
all that stuff
it that's not the greatest combination
there and then
hey you know when your team can't run
the football
and it's predicated on pass pass pass
pass
and then instead of running the football
we throw short passes
right and we just keep it short that's
kind of our de facto run game
when you play a team like baltimore
who's got an all-star secondary
it's going to be tough sledding you know
that'd be one team
with for pittsburgh where i know they're
2-0 against them this year but i'd go
man i hope they don't make the playoffs
i don't want to see them
i don't it's not a great match-up for
them and pittsburgh
yeah they're going to have to live this
style or live this life a little bit
because of their inability to really be
a balanced football team
or run a clock out when they are up i
mean we saw this happen to them early in
the year
but either way i think the positives are
still
you know big ben for the most part the
way he's taking care of the football
managing the football game
it's very impressive he understands what
his team is
and he puts them in good positions it
certainly wasn't his fault like you said
with the drops and all that but
it's going to be interesting to see down
the stretch when they play a team who
you know again is at full health
everything is going like maybe the
buffalo bills who their defense is
getting going and i have to have a hard
time thinking sean mcdermott is gonna
let them
in the short passing game go off on all
them that'll be a tough
struggle and that's going to be the type
of team that can give them problems
well and they're going to need to have
james connor back for that game he was
on the covet 19 reserve list
and uh we wish him the best because he's
got the cancer history as well so it's a
heightened concern
yeah of of of potential complications of
covet 19 but we
we hope the best for him and the
steelers hope to have him back because
the bills struggle against the run you
want to have your
best running backs available for that
game and that game is coming up
in uh the steelers have
the washington football team monday
night
and then they turn it around with that
trip to buffalo for sunday night
football
and that that looms to me as the biggest
challenge in fact i don't
i said after i picked the steelers to
lose to the bengals and joe burrow
and and the steelers blew them out that
i would never pick against the steelers
ever again so i can't break from that
by next week but that sure feels like
the most vulnerable spot to me
especially
given the way they played last night
chris yeah i mean definitely and then
balt i mean um
buffalo just you know they're on they're
one of those teams mike where
i think if you asked me five weeks ago i
would have gone
play off team maybe win one playoff game
i don't know if they can make a serious
run
but they've gotten healthy on defense
mcdermott
has got his creative bug going again
and the mad scientist and i don't know
what the hell defense and coverage this
is but everybody's covered going right
they got that they've really improved
the last few weeks
i mean you know we they played good
defense against the top five offense of
the chargers
you know we saw what they did to russell
wilson and company kyler murray and
company didn't have an easy time moving
the ball on them either
to where i start to go hey i know
pittsburgh kansas city and tennessee are
maybe in a little class of their own in
the afc
and i thought there was separation
between the next group there
but i think buffalo is right on the edge
there like
looking on the outside looking in and i
do i'm with you i think that'll be an
interesting match up and
uh fun to watch on sunday night next
week
bill's at two monday night games coming
up they have the 49ers in arizona
on this monday night then the next
primetime game sunday night this is an
opportunity for the bills to
to really show the the football watching
world what they have and they're going
to be fired up and they're going to be
ready to knock off the steelers when
they get the opportunity coming up here
in just about a week and a half
rg3 yeah let's let's hear from
rg3 after the game because he of all the
ravens who spoke and it's different than
a normal year where reporters can swarm
the locker room and get close
quotes but rg3 seemed to be
of the the people who spoke the most
upset by the way the delay was handled
and the way that the outbreak in
baltimore
was addressed here he is from after the
game
the walkthroughs weren't like a normal
practice by any stretch of imagination
it's probably unlike anything we've ever
done uh in our career
probably from little league to high
school to college
and definitely in the pros you know the
way the game went obviously we wanted to
win
we wanted to win the game but the way
the game was going
was uh you know a direct reflection how
we felt about the game we felt like we
had a chance to
come in here and win shock the world uh
and do something special
and we didn't do that and you know i put
that on myself because i felt like i let
the team down
um you know i know i don't think we're
supposed to really comment on injuries
but
i pulled my hamstring uh in the second
quarter
and i felt like if i hadn't done that
then we would have won this game
i mean it was obvious he pulled a
hamstring leg injury because he pulled
up and
uh kept going uh ultimately trace
mcsorley came in in the fourth quarter
but you know the the issue of the
walkthroughs yeah they had practice
monday and tuesday but i think they had
socially distanced practice like it's
not a real practice it really doesn't
get you ready
it's kind of quasi mental reps is what
you're getting
if you're the ravens in those two
practices and it's just not enough
for rg3 to be ready to go against a team
like the steelers but you know
he had he had a 40-yard run he ended up
with 68 yards rushing and maybe if he
doesn't pull the hamstring
there's a path there to the end zone oh
oh yeah
it was getting interesting i mean we saw
that hey
he could still run the football right i
mean that that was like what question
going in how effective can he be
i know we talked about that yesterday
and i thought he'd be effective enough
to scare
pittsburgh hey his speed was better than
i even gave it credit for as we saw in
some of those long runs
and you know i don't know if nicole in
the back room if you could bring those
pictures up again
i i i he's gonna score a touchdown
if he doesn't pull his hamstring on that
play like you're talking about there's a
pass so right there
then that picture you could tell he's
yeah he's grimacing because his
hamstring just pulled
but look at this here he is he's got the
edge
84 is going to go up to the free safety
minka fitzpatrick there at the
18 or 19 yard line on the hash and it's
gonna
be whether that guy down the field that
miles boykins blocking can get off the
block i mean it's gonna be
really close i'll just say that and it
certainly hurt their
chances of winning the football game in
a big way because
they were gonna need his legs to be that
threat to help them win their drop back
pass game we know it's below
average and then he hasn't played
football in a while so when you saw him
do that he went ah
man like this was kind of fun to watch i
mean baltimore was a real pain in the
butt for pittsburgh here and
once i saw him pull his hammy there like
that i just didn't you know you kind of
thought oh i don't know if he can hang
in there and i don't know if their
offense can move the ball enough without
that run threat
another thing he said after the game
that we really haven't focused on
because
the attention has been devoted to who
else is positive on the team how many
more positives today
can they somehow find a way to practice
can they find a way to play he pointed
out
look family members of the players and
coaches are catching it too
it's a serious situation for the ravens
organization it's been a huge
distraction for them
they've had a full-blown outbreak they
think it's under control now but
but but who knows and yeah the reality
is this
to the extent that there was any
glossing over of the tail end of the
outbreak and
geno jones the uh
um safety who ended up not being able to
play
because he tested positive tuesday he
was around the team on tuesday so
we're still kind of in that tick tick of
incubation period
where there could still be some right
some issues on the back end right yeah
because they were together
to travel on tuesday they were together
in the locker room
you know that playing the game itself
the nfl has gotten it right so far that
when you're
out there on the field in an open air
stadium or in a dome
when you're playing the chances of
transmitting to an
opponent are less than any one thought
because you're not around
someone long enough to transmit the
virus
but to get to the point where you're
playing
you've got to be on the plane in the bus
in the locker room
on the sideline there's so many other
ways to get it
yeah hey playing the game oh hey we're
not going to have transmission
but you don't just get dropped out of
the sky onto the field there's all these
other ways
that you're around other people and it's
the locker room that i think especially
the visiting team
locker room in so many of these stadiums
we talked about that before
in kansas city it's small you got
everybody jammed in there
you can't socially distance you can't do
it the right way
that's been one of the problems here and
that's contributed to the spread of the
virus among teams yeah
i mean there's no doubt you just you
can't avoid
it's hard to totally like in totality
avoid when you got
a fit you know 62 guys or however many
guys are on a damn roster right now
you know in locker rooms showers
everything like that
and some facilities some areas it's just
gonna be hard to have them like
always socially distanced and not next
to each other in those
in those type of scenarios so hopefully
baltimore has this under control
i mean wow what a rough week wow
i don't even under i mean as a player
i i just i i just it's amazing what
they're going through i'm surprised we
didn't see more pulled hamstrings last
night
because you're not really you know
athletes are like you know
sports cars they gotta get out and move
every now and then you gotta like you
know get the gas through all the
cylinders and pistons and get everything
going
if you just haven't been sitting in the
garage and all of a sudden you punch it
and put it in the sixth gear
these are the type of people that pull
hamstrings and that's the balance that i
worry about for these players too just
okay you're away from the facility uh
you know being in shape
running on your own whatever that's
that's a big part of this issue
just to make sure you're ready to go
when you do gotta play with with less
preparation
and on top of the physical aspect of it
when you spend a week
of are we going to play are we not going
to play are we comfortable playing are
we not comfortable playing
we don't want to play tuesday we won't
play at all
we'll not i mean when you've got that
bouncing around in your head
it becomes a distraction it becomes
the best thing i can compare it to chris
when i was practicing law in a trial was
coming up
i didn't want to know about any
possibility to settle the case once you
start getting that into your head you're
like well are we going to have a case
are we not going to have a case are we
going to settle the case are we not
what am i doing today am i going to
settle it on the on the steps to the
like i want to know this is it this is
when the
game starts once you know that you have
a clarity yes
where you can focus what they when did
they ever really get their clarity
that this thing was definitely happening
it wasn't until tuesday night
technically it wasn't until wednesday at
12 30 p.m
local time that the the the you know the
the what's the flag is it green
the green flag yes it's green means
guest right checkered flag is the end
well i'm talking about the flags they
wave at the start of a race you get the
green flag right at
three hours before kickoff yeah even
until then you're not sure they did all
those point-of-care tests yesterday
if there'd have been positives who the
hell know what would have happened so i
got a lot of respect for the ravens
making it as interesting as they made it
and i can understand why mike tomlin's
upset but mike you're 11-0
yeah so uh don't be mad be happy
well because you still have a chance to
go undefeated right only the the second
team ever to go 16-0 yeah
you're right there's still everything
they want still in front of them and
you know hey all the things you just
mentioned too
i think that's like you could easily
said i think that's why the pittsburgh
steelers were asleep at the wheel
last night you know or yesterday
afternoon whatever the hell that game
was
but you know imagine i i just thought
about first off big ben
because i thought his interview with
michelle tafoya after the game was very
funny
you know you could tell he was annoyed
by the week
and then he made a comment about getting
ready for watching he's like yeah what
do we do we playing a double header are
we getting ready to play right now like
you know he you could tell and i all i
can do is
you know let you know what it is like as
a quarterback
most of us are type a personalities we
love routine
this is the way our day's gonna go and
it's mapped out like perfectly
i mean i playing quarterback in a week
like last week i'm sure
there's days or a big oh man what the
hell what the f are we gonna do
are we playing are we not playing you
know what do i
do how do i practice today do i watch
film i mean it just throws you out of
your routine
all the way it's mentally exhausting too
and uh that led
to them probably not playing as their
best football
and then mike i gotta bring this up
because i know we're getting to the end
of our
segment maybe here you said
them asleep at the wheel cost them the
ability to get off the field
rest get ready for washington on a short
week
it also cost them maybe bud dupree
i mean bud dupree got hurt last day and
all reports are
indicating they think it's an acl man
that's a huge blow
he is such an awesome defensive player
that is the best pass rushing duo in
football
and now it's been split in half and that
stinks and i feel for him
because of course he's a franchise tag
guy too
and uh that'll hurt his chances of
getting big money in a contract
yeah and this is the worst time of year
to have that injury if you're going to
be a free agent in march because
what what are you going to say who's
going to offer you right
significant money when you are just a
few months in to rehab
from a torn acl and you know any time
that the reports pre-mri are that
clear that there's a belief there's a
torn acl that that means that they
they grab the knee and they start and oh
boy there's nothing you know there's
nothing there's nothing grabbing it
right
the ligament that holds this thing
together isn't intact we can tell
let's go ahead and do the mri so we see
the full extent of the damage
but yeah and it's it's unfortunate
and it's why guys like le'veon bell sat
out a full year
right you have to choose between taking
a significant
salary versus waiting for
the generational payday that comes from
a long-term contract where the team
assumes the risk
of that acl tear and you still get paid
the guaranteed money
that's what bud dupree didn't get and
that's what he's not going to get
in 2021 his best hope is going to be a
short-term deal
get back to the market and get the
payday then once you prove that the knee
is
is fine and you know for every adrian
peterson who comes back from an acl tear
good as new you you get a guy that that
maybe isn't the same
so you're not going to have a team make
that huge financial investment that bud
dupree
was clearly on track for given the kind
of year he was having so it's
it's an unfortunate aspect of the
business but
this is why we support guys like dak
prescott who refuse to accept
what's on the table that's right because
they they they want what they want
they're using
the system to their advantage because
the teams will use the system
to their advantage as well the steelers
using that franchise tag
kept bud dupree off the open market and
kept him from getting the payday he had
earned
and now this injury is going to keep him
from getting the next payday that
that he would have earned and uh we we
wish him the best as well but you're
right if you blow them out
he's not on the field in what would be
garbage time right
he's resting and he's getting ready for
monday night against washington yeah
i know that's that's the shame of it it
really is and you know you just i always
hate when it's a team that you have in
that you know
super bowl bubble super bowl convo you
want to see them at their best
through the year throughout the year and
now yeah their defense will not be at
its best this special defense that's a
super bowl caliber
can win games by itself almost type of
defense
uh this is this is going to make things
you know a little harder
they're still awesome there's still a
lot of good players but man he makes a
lot of plays
on the stat sheet and of course a lot of
the f to play
up type of plays that are not on the
stat sheet and that's where it stinks
and
yeah the damn franchise tag man i don't
know what to say i wish they'd do
something about it i don't know what
they can do they won't i know it's never
going away
i wish they could have a clause in the
contract like if you have this type of
injury
we got to give you a little extra money
after the year's over or something
just to ease the pain of some of these
players but uh either way it is what it
is i understand that and it's a
it's a brutal sport that's all i could
say it's brilliant yeah what the all you
can do is the player is carve off
a chunk of that franchise salary and
purchase insurance for yourself in the
event that you have the kind of injury
that keeps you from getting the payday
you want on the open market but
look i don't want to get into a whole
insurance industry right now that's the
reality is this they're not the reality
is this
career ending injury you're much more
likely to get your money than one of
these
loss of value policies because the only
commodity in the insurance business is
money
they're going to take your money in when
the time comes to pay the money out
they're going to fight they're going to
scratch
the claw to say no we're not paying you
so there is a downside to that as well
all right steelers have washington
buffalo cincinnati
indianapolis cleveland five chances left
there have been
other teams that started 11-0 and have
gotten that first loss everyone bought
the new england patriots
of 2007. we had a graphic of when that
first loss came i mean you
never know when the loss is coming you
never know when the graphic is coming
either
it is there it is and and
several teams 13-0 uh but yeah
that and you know those colts teams that
popped up there
2005 2009 you know they
would go through that annual debate of
do you leave your starters in do you go
for it do you try to finish off the
unbeaten record and
bill paulian i think more than tony
dungy had the attitude
of we have to get the starters off the
field because we don't want to get
somebody injured in a meaningless game
but you know if you get the one seed
locked down and i don't know if the
steelers gonna have to worry about that
they have to keep winning because
they've got the chiefs
yeah on their heels and uh and so
the the question of do we rest people
may never come up for the steelers if
the chiefs keep winning games no you're
right and you know
and and this graphic here is the perfect
example of why you can't fall asleep
with the wheel
it's not like these undefeated teams are
losing to other teams that are you know
nine and two
look at it i mean it's seven and seven
it's five and eight you know some eight
and fives a six and five
so it can happen at any moment and you
know i think like you said really
all the games could be the loss for
pittsburgh other than that cincinnati
game
yeah i understand they're gonna be
favored in the majority of them
really maybe all of them really there
might not be a game where they're not
favored here from here on out
but the colts you know buffalo like we
talked about cleveland
certainly are you know at least in the
class of pittsburgh to pull off an upset
win do something like that washington
will have to play a special type of game
in my opinion to beat pittsburgh on
monday
but either way with their defense and if
pittsburgh just sleep with the wheel
again
we know they can be they can be had that
way so we'll see
you know last thing i just want to bring
up too we had all those conversations
about the prop bets yesterday
um i think i won just want to rub it in
real quick before we go to commercial
break
oh whoa okay we're tied
we're tied oh and you went with the over
on dez bryant
man so there we were we picked
everything you know
somewhat okay i went with the under on
dez
you went with the over i win oh yeah
nobody you know why you know why i
didn't bring it up you know why i didn't
bring it up because you lost cares
because nobody cares somebody cares
there's a graphic
look at point spent nobody cares they're
sponsored yes
i said it hey pete's telling me i teased
it yesterday i teased it yesterday so
people would care then
today nobody cares so uh so we finished
the opening segment
with a fizzle hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports